le crime est d'une telle c'est tellement
sauvage se découpage et en plus un
découpage vraiment méticuleux et très
très sordide pourquoi pas très bien
Michel Pinto faire ça car il y a un
problème de taille Michel Pinto mesure
1m60 pour 55 kg comment dans ces
conditions a-t-il pu tuer et se
débarrasser de Francis Ben Mokhtar et
surtout de Jean-Pierre Caligaris qui
pesait sans dix kilos il y a peut-être
une explication toute simple
[Musique]
18 mars 1999 sur les petites routes
escarpées de l'arrière-pays niçois un
agent de la direction départementale de
l'équipement finissent sa journée de
surveillance ici près de Toulon les
routes sont étroites et à flanc de
falaise il n'est pas rare que des
pierres roulent sur la voie et entravent
le passage
pour dégager le chemin l'homme garde son
véhicule dans un virage mais lorsqu'il
descend il constate aussitôt quelque
chose d'anormal j'ai senti une odeur
mauvaise odeur
et ici comme on va à la chasse je
croyais que c'était un gibier mort ou
quoi
pour en avoir le cœur net l'agent de la
DDE décide d'inspecter le ravin
c'est alors qu'il aperçoit quelque chose
d'étrange en contrebas et là j'ai vu des
quelque chose dessous est à lui apporter
des sacs trois quatre cinq de poubelles
quoi poser un peu plus loin plus l'agent
s'approche et plus l'odeur devient
insoutenable arrivé à quelques mètres
des sacs il se rend vite compte qu'il ne
s'agit pas de simples déchets
j'ai dit qu'est-ce que c'est quand je
suis descend du voir et à ma prochaine
je me suis aperçu que
c'était une jambe d'humain et un bras
et j'ai pas cherché à comprendre je suis
pas allé voir quoi plus bas quoi
Jean-Marc Martin regagner rapidement son
véhicule et par prévenir la gendarmerie
la plus proche
les gendarmes de rockesteron arrivent
très vite sur place face à la gravité de
la découverte la brigade de recherche de
Nice les rejoint quelques minutes plus
tard tout ce qu'on prenne qu'ils ont
affaire à un crime hors du commun les
enquêteurs quand ils vont ouvrir ses
sacs
vont avoir un véritable puzzle avec
toutes ces morceaux de corps de reste
humain des corps découpés visiblement
et à partir de là le décompte macabre va
intervenir combien de sacs et dans
chacun ses sacs combien de reste cela
fait plusieurs heures maintenant que les
recherches ont commencé les gendarmes
ratissent méticuleusement se paysage
accidenté pour ramasser chaque reste de
cadavres une tâche rendue
particulièrement difficile par
l'obscurité à la nuit tombée le
lieutenant-colonel Fombonne arrive sur
place et assiste à une scène sordide
j'arrête la voiture à la limite de la
tresse gendarmerie ne pas franchir à la
limite de la scène de crime et j'ai la
vision de mon chef d'équipe de
techniciens des notifications
criminelles qui sort du ravin et il
porte un morceau de cadavre
les premières constatations laissent
penser que ces membres proviennent de
trois corps différents
mais il y a un détail très troublant il
n'y a pas de main il n'y a pas de pied
il manque des éléments des corps en
particulier des têtes les restes en tout
cas ont été dévissées cela ne fait plus
aucun doute en faisant disparaître
certains membres le ou les auteurs du
crime ont voulu retarder
l'identification des cadavres d'ailleurs
en jetant les corps dans cette région
sauvage le ou les meurtriers espérer
sans doute que les corps ne soit jamais
découverts c'est une route qui fait 10
km elle était droite il passe pas
beaucoup de monde quoi et passer le
facteur nous de la DDE quoi par jour il
faut 400 voitures
c'est sauvage il y a rien quoi je
m’arrêtais pas à cet endroit là personne
n'aurait jamais trouvé
à ce stade les enquêteurs ne disposent
d'aucune piste tous les scénarios sont
possibles même les plus extravagants une
secte par exemple ou alors un acte de
d'une personne déséquilibrée ou alors
pourquoi pas une mauvaise farce l'une
des possibilités c'était effectivement
des
étudiants médecine qui aurait découpé
des corps et les auraient jetés dans le
dans la nature on a pensé à la mafia
ruse on a pensé à plusieurs pistes les
recherches continuent jusqu'au petit
matin mais en dehors des sacs poubelles
et des morceaux de corps les gendarmes
ne trouvent aucun élément matériel
et tout de suite cette affaire qui
commençait comme une découverte de
cadavres j'allais dire presque banal
devient immédiatement quelque chose
d'extraordinaire au sens au sens
étymologique du temps pour tout le monde
c'est le mystère qu'est-il arrivé à ses
cadavres une énigme que les enquêteurs
ne pourront résoudre qu'en répondant à
une question à qui appartiennent ces
corps retrouvés dans leur Avin de
l'espérance
trois corps mutilés ont été découverts
près de Nice Centre Gilette et
orchesteron on en connaîtra sans doute
un peu plus après l'autopsie qui a été
demandé
pour avancer dans leurs investigations
les gendarmes espèrent beaucoup des
résultats des autopsies un travail qui
s'avère pour le moins surréaliste
faut ranger ses morceaux humains classés
ces morceaux humains c'était absolument
incroyable c'est une espèce de puzz
qu'on fait les légistes en étiquant les
chacune des parties qu'ils avaient
retrouvées et peu à peu en mettant en
fait trois trois tas non seulement les
têtes les mains et les pieds ont disparu
mais les sexes des hommes ont été coupés
et les viscères sont mélangés et
pourtant après plusieurs heures de
travail se sordide puzzle finit par
donner de riches d'indications
il y a trois morphologies totalement
différentes il y a une femme qui a
l'évidence est une femme déjà d'un
certain âge
qui a eu
vraisemblablement de l'archéologie
réparatrice voir esthétique deux hommes
un qui est d'une très forte corpulence
un deuxième qui est d'une soixantaine
d'années et qui pourrait être maghrébin
on a un sexe qui circoncis on a une
pilosité qui est plutôt frisée et même
si les corps sont déjà très délabrés on
a une coloration de la peau qui n'est
pas tout à fait celle d'un caucasien qui
est pas qui est un petit peu
Méditerranée autre élément apporté par
l'autopsie et pas des moindres l'un des
corps présente une trace de projectile
un projectile 22 long rifle
c'est le seul projectile que l'on
retrouvera et ce n'est pas tout les
résultats des analyses laisse apparaître
un élément qui va interpeller les
enquêteurs et cela concerne l'estomac
des victimes
[Musique]
au bol digestif des trois estomacs et
dans le même état de digestion c'est à
dire qu'ils ont mangé la même chose et
l'ont mangé au même moment donc tout ça
confirme bien que
les trois victimes visiblement sont
mortes ensemble et au même moment
l'autopsie permet donc aux enquêteurs
d'avoir plusieurs certitudes le jour de
leur mort les victimes deux hommes et
une femme ont mangé ensemble un plat à
base de sanglier accompagné de haricots
verts les médecins légistes parviennent
même à dater ce repas entre le 26 et le
27 février 1999 soit 3 semaines avant la
découverte des corps la sauvagerie de ce
triple crime fait immédiatement la une
de l'actualité après la découverte
macabre de trois corps mutilés le
parquet ouvert une information
judiciaire pour meurtre suivi d'acte de
barbarie selon les premiers éléments de
l'enquête il s'agirait des cadavres de
deux hommes et d'une femme
la médiatisation de ce fait divers
permet à l'enquête d'avancer
[Musique]
moins de 5 jours après la découverte
macabre de l'espérance les gendarmes
niçois reçoivent un appel
particulièrement intéressant
femme s'inquiète de Pan voir de
nouvelles de son frère parce qu'elle a
vu justement dans la presse qui s'est
fait écho de cette trouvaille macabre la
description d'un homme corpulent elle se
dit tiens mon frère est corpulent il est
de la dans la région j'ai pas de Noël de
lui mon frère ne donne plus signe de vie
depuis plusieurs semaines alors qu'il a
l'habitude d'appeler
notre mère donc ce que dit cette femme
notre mère tous les dimanches à midi
pile la jeune femme leur donne alors
l'identité de son frère il s'appelle
Jean-Pierre Caligaris originaire
d'Ajaccio cet homme de 40 ans est connu
des services de police pour avoir
participé à des trafics de stupéfiants
en région parisienne depuis un an il
s'est mis au vert sur la Côte d'Azur
s'agit-il de l'un des corps retrouvé une
seule solution pour le savoir
il suffit de prélever l'empreinte
génétique de la sœur de calgaris
et la techniquement ça va très vite on
fait un prélèvement sur cette sur cette
femme on fait une comparaison d'ADN avec
un des trois corps et effectivement
c'est bien Jean-Pierre Caligari qui est
connu comme étant un trafiquant de
stupéfiant
reste maintenant à identifier les deux
autres victimes grâce à l'autopsie on
sait qu'il s'agit d'un homme d'origine
maghrébine et d'une femme deux personnes
que Jean-Pierre Caligaris connaissait
forcément pour avoir partagé leur
dernier repas
[Musique]
l'identification des deux autres
victimes va s'enchaîner parce que nous
savons que ce sont des personnes qui
sont dans son entourage très proche on
va s'apercevoir qu'il est effectivement
sur la côte depuis quelques temps et
qu'il fréquente de façon très proche de
personnes qui sont belles Mokhtar et
Madame conte Francis Benmokhtar lui
aussi est un habitué des services de
police à 58 ans c'est un truand réputé
de la Côte d'Azur un gros bonnet dont
Jean-Pierre Caligaris était devenu le
garde du corps
quant à la troisième victime il s'agit
de Teresa comte 53 ans c'est la compagne
de Benmokhtar il aura fallu plusieurs
semaines pour identifier les trois
victimes
reste maintenant à savoir pourquoi ils
ont été assassinés et surtout par qui
les victimes identifiées leur pedigre et
dévoilée c'est tout naturellement que
des gendarmes vont échafauder une
hypothèse pour expliquer ce triple crime
on part d'un mystère vraiment total et
ensuite on arrive assez vite dans
l'hypothèse dans une espèce de
d'environnement qui laisserait penser un
règlement de compte particulièrement
violent dans le milieu du grand
banditisme
sous-direction des stupéfiants si on
peut dire imaginé de suite par par les
enquêteurs et par et par les spectateurs
et Parlement judiciaires que c'était un
crime mafieux et que c'était une
nouvelle mafia la mafia de drop de l'Est
qui était entrée en ligne de compte et
dans cette affaire
seulement quelque chose ne colle pas
avec la thèse mafieuse car dans le grand
banditisme on n'a pas pour habitude
d'utiliser le calibre 22 long rifle
l'arme qui justement a servi à tuer
Jean-Pierre calgaris Le 22 Long et le
calibre 22 long rifle n'est pas le
calibre habituellement
utilisé employé par les gens du milieu
on utilise du 11 43 on utilise
kalachnikov on utilise des armes
beaucoup plus puissantes que une vanne
de long rifle le crime mafieux écarté
les enquêteurs se demandent si tout
simplement le mobile ne serait pas
l'argent car Francis Benmokhtar l'une
des trois victimes disposait d'une
petite fortune et dans la région tout le
monde le savait
son surnom c'était le riche le riche
pourquoi parce que il était en autorité
publique qu'il était la tête d'une
petite fortune cet argent il le conserve
dans une dans une glacière bleue une
glacière de camping mais une glacière de
grand volume c'est son portefeuille il
est décrit par tous ceux qui l'ont
approché comme quelqu'un qui se déplace
avec la glacière et qui a toujours son
argent sur lui à l'époque on parle d'un
million de dollars c'est une somme qui
est quand même qui est quand même mais
encore à l'époque davantage considérable
un million de dollars près de 750 000
euros des rumeurs évoquent même impactol
2 voire trois fois plus élevé de
l'argent illicite qui suscite de
nombreuses convoitises et qui oblige
Benmokhtar à vivre caché l'homme change
souvent d'adresse et aussi d'identité
difficile pour les gendarmes d'enquêter
dans ces conditions heureusement de
mystérieux coup de téléphone anonymes
vont leur venir en aide un certain
nombre d'appels anonymes seront dirigés
vers la gendarmerie qui mène cette
enquête dont un ou deux particulièrement
troublant qui vont donner l'adresse
précise du lieu où est domicilié Francis
Benoît
l'informateur de la gendarmerie qui
donne aux enquêteurs de la section des
recherches l'endroit à Antibes 502
chemin de la suquette où il est
susceptible d'avoir loué une ville
[Musique]
quelques heures à peine après avoir eu
connaissance de son adresse les
gendarmes se rendent chez Francis
Benmokhtar et immédiatement il se
rendent compte que quelque chose
d'étrange s'est produit
que la résidence était totalement vidée
de l'intégralité de ce qui s'y trouve
aucun indice aucune trace
la seule certitude c'est que la maison
était vidée plus personne ne l'a dit
depuis la disparition de Francis ben de
Mokhtar et de sa compagne on a fait le
ménage
Francis Benmokhtar avait-il quitté sa
villa avant de se faire tuer ou
quelqu'un a-t-il voulu faire disparaître
les effets personnels de la victime
mystère
pour le savoir les enquêteurs décident
de contacter l'agence immobilière qui
gère la villa sur place le gérant
explique qu'il ne connaît pas Francis
Ben Mokhtar car la propriété était louée
à un autre homme nous l'appellerons
Monsieur Jacques l'homme a tout faire du
truand
c'est un proche de Ben Mokhtar c'est un
petit peu le factotum c'est celui qui
s'occupe de toute la logistique c'est
lui qui s'occupe des agences
immobilières pour éventuellement louer
un appartement c'est lui qui s'occupe
des voyages c'est lui qui s'occupe de la
logistique de Ben Mokhtar et l'agent
immobilier d'ajouter un élément
troublant Monsieur Jacques lui aurait
restitué les clés de la villa de
Benmokhtar à la fin du mois de mars
autrement dit presque un mois après la
mort des trois victimes alors Monsieur
Jacques pourrait-il être mêlé au crime
de l’estéron il est temps de
l'interroger
connu des services de police pour des
petits délits Monsieur Jacques est
facilement retrouvé face aux gendarmes
il confirme travailler pour Benmokhtar
mais il n'y tout implication dans sa
mort d'ailleurs il ajoute que la
dernière fois qu'il a vu son patron
c'était le 27 février le jour présumé du
meurtre en fin de matinée dans le jardin
de Francis Benmokhtar les dépositions de
sont particulièrement intéressantes
parce qu'il ressort qu'il est l'un des
derniers à avoir rencontré les victimes
vivantes et là il va être très précis
puisqu'il va même nous dire le 27
février matin je passe leur dire bonjour
comme j'ai l'habitude de passer et il
devait
les revoir dit-il le lendemain le
dimanche dans l'après-midi
seulement Monsieur Jacques raconte que
le lendemain lorsqu'il arrive chez
Benmokhtar il trouve la porte de la
villa ouverte les lumières et la
télévision sont allumées mais il n'y a
personne il précise même qu'un détail
attire son attention la glacière bleue
et là mais elle est vide
en entendant Monsieur Jacques les
gendarmes sont tout de même circonspects
car l'homme ne leur inspire pas
confiance
c'est un type qui a une voix extrêmement
grave un physique de on dirait un peu un
personnage échappé d'un film de gangster
à la audiarde des années 60 je pense que
pour un policier c'est il attire
forcément l'attention quand on se dit
qu'il est pas net les gendarmes sont
méfiants certes mais tout ce qui
explique Monsieur Jacques par écrit son
patron s'est en volatilisé c'est lui
dit-il qui a déménagé la villa de
Benmokhtar et qui a rendu les clés à
l'agence et l'homme va même livrer une
information capitale
[Musique]
souvenez-vous on sait que les trois
victimes ont mangé ensemble le jour de
leur mort et bien Monsieur Jacques va
révéler aux gendarmes qu'il les a
invitées
apprend que
le trio c'est à dire les deux hommes et
la femme sont invités à dîner le soir
même c'est-à-dire le 27 février chez le
fromager le fromager c'est un certain
Michel pinotto qui a un commerce donc
agent les pins
Jean-Pierre Caligaris Francis Benmokhtar
et Teresa s'accompagnent aurait donc
pris leur dernier repas chez un fromager
de Juan-les-Pins un dénommé Michel Pinto
pour les gendarmes il est urgent
d'entendre le commerçant
lorsqu'ils arrivent à la fromagerie de
Michel Pinto les gendarmes sont surpris
car l'homme n'a rien d'incriminel bien
au contraire le fromager semble être un
commerçant paisible d'ailleurs ce
citoyen de 62 ans n'a jamais eu à faire
à la justice mais chose étranges au
moment où les gendarmes interrogent
Pinto sur ses liens avec Benmokhtar le
fromage est ni en bloc il dit ne pas le
connaître
en fait c'est il a rien vu rien entendu
il connaît personne alors qu'on a quand
même un renseignement
de l'eau qui
on voit pas très bien
mis ce Pinto dans le circuit s'il est
pas du tout quoi intrigué les gendarmes
fouillent alors dans le passé de Michel
Pinto et se rendent vite compte que le
fromager ne leur a pas dit toute la
vérité
quelques années auparavant
pinoto avait été
impliqué dans une affaire
de stupéfiants il avait passé du
haschich pour le compte du jeune
délinquant et Ben Mokhtar et ils ont été
tous les deux tous les deux condamnés de
la prise en fer dès lors le fromager ne
peut plus nier ses liens avec Francis
Benmokhtar et bientôt il ne pourra plus
ni avoir organisé chez lui un dîner avec
les trois victimes quelques heures avant
leur mort car ce jour-là Jean-Pierre
Caligaris l'un des trois convives a reçu
un coup de fil de sa compagne à 21h
c'est relevés téléphoniques le prouvent
et voici ce qui lui a dit il lui a dit
qu'il était Antibes qu'il dînait chez
les pinotos et qu'il était accompagné de
Francis et de Thérèse et là l'ami de
Jean-Pierre cagliaris dira aux
enquêteurs je n'ai plus Jean-Pierre au
téléphone j'ai rappelé plusieurs fois
son téléphone le soir même et je suis
systématiquement tombé sur la boîte
vocale alors pourquoi Michel Pinto
a-t-il caché ce repas au gendarmes ces
mensonges le place immédiatement en
position de suspect numéro 1 on part
tout de suite sur une version qui n'est
pas effectivement conforme à la réalité
ça c'est pas bon
dans les jours qui suivent les
enquêteurs approfondissent leurs
investigations sur Michel Pinto très
rapidement ils mettent en évidence
plusieurs éléments troublants à
commencer par son mode de vie l'homme
mène grand train étonnant pour un simple
petit commerçant
il a manifestement un train de vie qui
dépasse les ressources officielles de ce
commerce
un penchant pour le luxe on apprend
qu'il a un bateau notamment on apprend
qu'il aime les voitures de sport
quelqu'un qui virait un petit peu
au-dessus de ses moyens
et ce n'est pas tout les analyses ont
démontré que Jean-Pierre Caligaris avait
reçu une balle de 22 long rifle dans le
dos un type de calibre fréquemment
utilisé pour les chasseurs et justement
Michel Pinto pratique la chasse
des chasseurs il ne s'en est d'ailleurs
jamais caché et il a une bonne
connaissance du maniement de ce type
d'armes c'est une certitude il va dire
parce qu'évidemment on va lui poser la
question qui n'a jamais été en
possession d'une arme de calibre 22 mais
on a des témoins qui vont nous dire si
si effectivement
Pinto a eu une arme
alors pour en avoir le cœur net les
gendarmes organisent une perquisition
chez le fromager objectif trouver l'arme
du crime à l'intérieur de la maison
aucun 22 long rifle en revanche dans le
jardin
les enquêteurs détectent quelque chose
de très intéressant
lors des investigations faites dans le
jardin seront découverts des études de
22 longs il a dû s'amuser à faire un
carton dans son jardin et il y a des
douilles il y a des étuis qui sont qui
sont dissimulés dans le sol et qu'on va
trouver au détecteur de métaux malgré
cette découverte et aussi incroyable que
cela puisse paraître le fromager
continue de nier il n'a jamais eu de
carabine 22 long rifle face à ses
mensonges pas tant les gendarmes savent
qu'ils n'ont plus qu'une seule solution
entreprendre un interrogatoire musclé du
fromager et de son épouse
28 septembre 1999 au matin le couple
Pinto est interpellé à son domicile et
placée en garde à vue les gendarmes
savent que pour obtenir la vérité la
seule solution est de les interroger
séparément mais le fromager s'obstine
non il n'y a jamais eu de dîner chez lui
ce 27 février la position de principe de
Pineto c'est de contester l'existence
même du repas ça sera sa position lors
de la garde à vue
un type qui
parle avec beaucoup de véhément c'est un
culot mais exceptionnel quoi il peut il
peut dire n'importe quoi
sans rougir quoi il est il est
stupéfiant quoi de naturel bon c'est pas
toujours très convaincant mais il se
démonte pas en revanche ce que pinoto
ignore c'est que dans le bureau d'à côté
sa femme Joël résiste moins bien à
l'insistance des enquêteurs elle nie
durant plusieurs dizaines de minutes
mais peu à peu comment ça va scier son
épouse
qu'effectivement il y a eu un repas
qu'on a reçu le trio à la maison elle
donne même le menu de ce repas et ce
menu correspond à ce que l'on a retrouvé
dans le bol alimentaire en cours de
digestion des cadavres retrouvés Joël
Pinto confirme le menu du dîner ce
soir-là du sanglier haricots verts mais
elle évoque aussi une pâtisserie une
tarte aux pommes dont on ne retrouve
aucune trace dans l'estomac des victimes
ce qui laisse penser aux enquêteurs que
les convives n'auraient pas eu le temps
de prendre leur dessert
il semble bien effectivement que ce
repas était curieusement interrompu en
tout cas qu'il a été mis fin à ce repas
de façon un peu brutale peu abrupte
l'épouse du fromager est sommet de
s'expliquer pourquoi ces invités
n'ont-ils pas pris de décès au bout de
quelques instants elle va finir par
reconnaître que ils sont partis avant la
fin du repas brutalement
après avoir reçu un coup de fil qui
semble perturbé Francis Benmokhtar va
bondir se lever en disant ben voilà on y
va et elle va même aller plus loin
puisque au cours de sa garde à vue elle
va dire mais Michel donc son mari les a
accompagnés et parti avec eux
donc là on a quand même bien avancé
Joël Pinto ne s'arrête pas là elle
déclarait également que son mari ne
serait rentré au domicile que beaucoup
plus tard dans la nuit vers 5h du matin
une longue absence qui leur est
justifiée en évoquant un gros problème
une emboucane comme on dit dans le
sud-est on a eu dans bocal ce sont Terre
vous êtes tombés dans un piège dans un
guet-apens
il n'en dira pas plus
il se naît qu'il fallait garder le
silence et qu'il fallait pas en parler
si Joël Pinto a mis du temps à révéler
ses détails c'est justement parce que
son mari lui aurait demandé à plusieurs
reprises de garder le silence elle se
souvient d'ailleurs d'un autre détail
étrange
lorsque la manchette de Nice-Matin titre
massacre de l’esteron
Joël rend connaissance du titre le
montre à son mari ou inversement et lui
tout de suite va appeler mire et il va
dire à son épouse
tu ne dois jamais dire qu'ils sont venus
dîner à la maison
fort des confessions de Joël Pinto
Michel son mari continuera-t-il à nier
encore longtemps l'existence de ce dîner
en attendant le couple est mis en examen
pour triple assassinat
48 heures se sont écoulés depuis
l'arrestation du fromager face aux
déclarations de son épouse Michel Pinto
finit par reconnaître maintenant
l'existence du repas et va même raconter
comment selon lui la soirée a viré au
drame ce soir-là Francis Benmokhtar lui
aurait demandé de mettre à l'abri sa
glacière rempli de billets de banque
chose curieuse le truand a l'air pressé
car il demande à son hôte d'abréger le
repas car il veut vite lui remettre
l'argent liquide Michel Pinto et
Jean-Pierre Caligaris accompagne donc
Francis Benmokhtar et sa compagne à leur
domicile seulement lorsqu'ils arrivent
sur place les choses auraient mal tourné
il les raccompagne au domicile de
Benmokhtar
et là des hommes cagoulés
les agresse
selon le fromager deux hommes masqués et
armés de 22 Long rifles les auraient
donc menacé Michel Pinto raconte qu'il
assiste impuissant à une scène d'une
violence inouïe Benmokhtar s'accompagne
et Jean-Pierre Caligaris sont tenus en
joues plaqués à terre et déshabiller je
vais indiquer que un moment il voit
Jean-Pierre Caligari se relever
et l'un des deux membres de ce commando
lui tirer une balle de 22 long rifle
dans l'épaule droite le commando aurait
ensuite abattu Benmokhtar et sa compagne
d'une balle dans la tête
[Musique]
toujours selon le fromager sous la
menace les deux agresseurs leur est
contraint à procéder à la découpe des
corps
[Musique]
forcer par ce commando il accomplit
cette tâche découpe les corps remplit
les sacs et puis finalement encore sous
la direction encore sous la menace de ce
commando va se rendre dans le massif de
l'espérance pour y jeter les corps le
massif de l'eston un secteur que le
fromager connaît bien pour y chasser
habituellement le sanglier et là une
première interrogation qui surgit
Michel pinotto à l'issue de cet
événement et bien rentre chez lui
librement pas davantage inquiété par les
membres du commando auxquels ils
viennent prêter son aide le récit de
Pinto interpelle juger enquêteur car
malgré l'aspect rocambolesque de son
témoignage certains détails de ce qu'il
raconte ne peuvent pas avoir été
inventés et notamment des éléments
balistiques liés à la mort de
Jean-Pierre Caligaris la manière dont
une auto nous décrit la façon dont le
coup de feu a été tiré correspond à des
constatations balistiques qu'on a pu
faire sur son morceau de corps la balle
a pénétré
d'arrière en avant de bas en haut
et dans l'épaule droite
ces indications là
n'ont jamais été diffusé dans la presse
alors Michel Pinto aurait-il été ce
soir-là le témoin forcé d'un guet-apens
meurtrier ou aurait-il inventé cette
histoire de commando pour maquiller son
triple meurtre
ou il est l'auteur de ce fait où il en
est le témoin où il en est le témoin
direct c'est-à-dire que quelqu'un le lui
a raconté mais il ne peut pas être
complètement étranger
pourtant le lendemain matin coup de
théâtre Michel Pinto du fond de sa
cellule dans un courrier envoyé au juge
d'instruction va surprendre tout le
monde
il va très rapidement se rétracter et
revenir sur ses aveux il va se rétracter
en indiquant que il n'a jamais il n'a
jamais rien vu de tout cela et que et
que on lui a fait dire n'importe quoi
parce qu'il était fatigué
nous nous sommes procurés le courrier
que le fromager écrit au juge depuis sa
prison
en voici un extrait
monsieur le juge comme je vous l'ai dit
de vive voix devant Monsieur le
Procureur je vous ai servi une belle
salade que vous rêviez d'entendre ce
revirement totalement inattendu mais un
sérieux coup de frein à l'enquête
seulement le magistrail des gendarmes
n'ont pas encore dit leur dernier mot
même s'il s'est rétracté les gendarmes
décident de vérifier méthodiquement les
déclarations de Michel Pinto il commence
par chercher des traces de sang sur le
lieu supposé du crime c'est à dire le
garage de Francis Benmokhtar et là
surprise
rien
aucune trace de sang dans la villa de
benmokhtarescante alors les gendarmes se
demandent si Michel Pinto ne leur a pas
menti et si le triple crime avait eu
lieu chez lui après le dîner il se
rendent donc sur place pour vérifier
s'il n'y aurait pas des traces de sang
et là ils vont faire une bien troublante
découverte quelques semaines après le
crime le fromager a entièrement fait
refaire sa cuisine quand on
perquisitionne chez pinoto on constate
qu'une pièce était refaite de fond en
comble carrelage compris que la cuisine
a été modifiée
ces travaux interviennent à un moment
singulièrement opportun pour lui pinoto
et sa femme et inopportun pour les
enquêteurs
pour les gendarmes ces travaux auraient
pu permettre à pinoto de masquer des
taches de sang et ce n'est pas la seule
chose qui étonne les enquêteurs le coût
de la rénovation estimé à 40000 euros
semble totalement disproportionné
comparé aux faibles revenus du fromage
ces travaux ont été payés en espèces
et puis
on constate également
que Michel pinotto et son épouse Joël
ont un coffre en banque et fait
troublant après le 27 février jour
supposé d'humeurtre Michel Pinto s'est
rendu à plusieurs reprises à sa banque
déposées dans son coffre de l'argent
liquide 27 février samedi dimanche 28
février lundi 1er mars bien souvent les
banques sont fermées le lundi mardi le 2
mars
première visite de pinoto à son coffre
et là les visites vont s'enchaîner en
additionnant les sommes placées par
Michel Pinto les gendarmes aboutissent à
un total d'environ 500 000 euros
l'argent pourrait donc faire figure de
mobiles parfait et Pinto de coupable
idéal seulement plusieurs choses ne
collent pas il n'est a priori pas du
calibre de des victimes donc
assez étonnant qu'un
petit poisson comme ça s'en prennent à
des gros poissons et puis encore une
fois
le crime est d'une telle c'est tellement
sauvage se découpage et en plus un
découpage vraiment
méticuleux très très sordide on voit pas
très bien Michel Pinto faire ça car il y
a un problème de taille Michel Pinto
mesure 1m60 pour 55 kg comment dans ces
conditions a-t-il pu tuer et se
débarrasser de Francis Ben Mokhtar et
surtout de Jean-Pierre Caligaris qui
pesait 110 kg il y a peut-être une
explication toute simple
une hypothèse est alors évoquée et si
Michel Pinto avait profité du fameux
dîner du 27 février pour droguer ses
convives
[Musique]
à ce moment-là ils sont des proies
faciles ils sont des proies à la portée
d'un Pinteau un mètre 60 et 55 kg et là
les gendarmes vont se souvenir de
l'appel que Jean-Pierre Caligaris a reçu
dans la soirée de la part de sa compagne
l'ami va dire aux enquêteurs j'ai eu
Jean-Pierre au téléphone il était pas
dans son état normal
alors pour vérifier la thèse des
somnifères plusieurs prélèvements sont à
nouveau effectués sur les corps des
trois victimes quelques jours plus tard
le rapport est formel
au moins les deux hommes on semble-t-il
absorbé un produit
type somnifères très fort du Rohypnol
alors c'est vrai que
ils étaient les uns et les autres en
tout cas les deux hommes victimes
cocaïnoman et que l'Europe peut être
aussi pris pour atténuer les effets de
la cocaïne en fin de prise je dirais
mais pour autant ce n'est pas une
hypothèse à écarter au final on ne saura
jamais avec certitude si les victimes
ont été drogués avant d'être tués
mais il y a un nouvel élément qui va
venir aggraver la situation de Michel
Pinto cela se passe à Lamotte-Beuvron à
850 km de Juan-les-Pins c'est là que le
fromager habitait avant de venir
s'installer dans le sud de la France et
les enquêteurs vont avoir une idée
par un quai de conscience les gendarmes
vont aller voir l'armurerie
du village
et la surprise
[Musique]
en étudiant en recherchant dans les
registres
[Musique]
de l'armurier il constate l'achat d'une
22 long rifle avec silencieux par Michel
pinotto en 1989 pourtant Michel Pinto a
toujours ni avoir possédé une carabine
22 long rifle cette fois comment va-t-il
parvenir à ce justifier mais là encore
le fromager a réponse à tout
[Musique]
face à cette contradiction contre
laquelle il ne peut rien pinoto
rebondira en disant que finalement c'est
vrai il était bien propriétaire d'une 22
long rifle mais qu'au moment des faits
il l'avait prêté ou donné à son ami Ben
Mokhtar
cette explication du fromager semble peu
crédible maintenant pour les gendarmes
tout semble l'accuser le repas l'argent
la piste du somnifère est maintenant le
22 long rifle face à tous ces éléments
qu'il accuse Michel Pinto donne une
nouvelle version du dîner après le repas
ces trois convives quittent la table
cette fois-ci Pinto explique qu'il ne
serait pas parti avant eux mais
seulement quelques minutes plus tard et
qu'en arrivant au domicile de Francis
Benmokhtar il aurait surpris le commando
le fromager ce serait alors caché dans
un buisson et aurait assisté impuissant
au triple crime arriver sur les lieux
pouvez avoir qu'il y a une emboutane
c'est comme ça qu'il a décrit ce qu'il a
entrevue à savoir que le trio était
tombé sur un commando qu'il avait entre
aperçu
des silhouettes que les choses se
passaient très mal à l'évidence il
entend un coup de feu alors qu'il
s'enfuit dans des fourrés que sais-je
enfin il disparaît et il reste terréla
un certain nombre d'heures avant de
rentrer chez lui après avoir constaté
que tout le monde a disparu du garage de
Ben Mokhtar sinon il a pas du tout forcé
il n'y a pas du tout participé au
découpage des corps mais il a vu la
scène
il a vu la scène et il est caché
derrière un
cette nouvelle version peine à
convaincre les gendarmes sans compter
une dernière découverte qui va
définitivement renforcer la conviction
des enquêteurs
cela fait maintenant 9 mois que les
trois corps ont été retrouvés dans la
vallée de l'eston lors d'une patrouille
de routine les gendarmes retrouvent les
deux véhicules appartements aux victimes
et ils ne sont pas garer n'importe où
ils ont été placés sur le parking de
l'aéroport côté départ internationaux le
meurtrier qui ne pensait pas que les
sacs poubelles contenant les corps
allait être découverts
aurait sans doute voulu faire croire à
un départ volontaire du trio pour
l'étranger
[Musique]
lors d'un procès qui s'annonce riche en
rebondissements
[Musique]
vous venez sans aucun doute du triple
meurtre du massif de l'Esteron où les
corps des victimes avaient été
atrocement mutilés
dans ce procès qui s'ouvre ce 4 novembre
2002 au palais de justice de Nice tout
semble accusé Michel Pinto et pourtant
c'est la stupeur lorsqu'il apparaît dans
le box des accusés en détention
provisoire depuis 3 ans l'homme a
vieilli et de toute évidence il a subi
un tabassage en règle
du procès
puis de toi était victime d'une
agression à la maison d'arrêt
et il arrive tuméfié
large bandeau sur la tête
des
des cocards sous les yeux et il explique
qu'on a voulu à tenter à sa vie à la
maison d'arrêt plusieurs hypothèses soit
il s'en est pris on considère qu'il s'en
est pris à des gens importants du milieu
comme pouvait l'être Ben Mokhtar et que
la manière dont il les atrucidés
méritent une punition soit ce que
essaiera de soutenir pinotau cette
correction avez vocation à le faire
taire parce que il pouvait lors de ce
procédé d'assise mettre en cause des
personnes qui étaient les véritables
assassins de Ben Mokhtar de contes et de
galliaris les débats commencent à peine
et un premier coup de théâtre va se
produire le procureur de la République
de Nice reçoit une lettre d'un ancien
compagnon de cellules de Michel Pinto un
certain Laurent Romeo c'est Laurent
Romeo Laurent Romeo il est détenu au
même endroit que pinoto la maison
d'arrêt de Nice et aurait eu des
confidences de la part depuis
dans ce courrier Laurent Romeo demande à
être reçu de toute urgence par le
procureur il a des révélations à faire
[Musique]
car en prison le fromager lui aurait
donné un certain nombre d'instructions
[Musique]
il veut récupérer
les voitures ils donnent dans tout
l'instruction à ces nouveaux amis de
faire disparaître de faire encore le
ménage le témoignage de l'ex détenu
Romeo semble accablant pour Michel
pinotto le procès est immédiatement
interrompu le temps pour les gendarmes
de vérifier ce nouvel élément Pinto lui
retourne en prison
les enquêteurs cherchent à vérifier si
le témoignage de Laurent Romeo est
crédible parmi ces révélations l'ex
détenu a indiqué que Pineto aurait
confié son 22 long rifle à un ami
restaurateur adjoint les pins les
gendarmes se rendent donc chez cet homme
et c'est au fond de son jardin d'un
simple tour de clé que celui-ci va
mettre fin à l'une des grandes
interrogations de la faire
on va retrouver 4 ans après effet cette
carabine et comparaisons sont faites par
les balisticiens et c'est effectivement
l'arme du crime
cette fois on est certain que c'est bien
l'arme de Michel Pinto qui a servi à
tuer Jean-Pierre Caligaris le soir du
crime fort de ses nouvelles informations
le procès peut reprendre donc quand on
revient après ce supplément
d'information et l'épisode de la 22
personnes n'ont plus guerre de chance
avec Michel Pinocchio de pouvoir s'en
sortir
[Musique]
le 16 septembre 2004 à la reprise du
procès Michel Pinto clame toujours son
innocence
il admet s'être débarrassé de son arme
mais comme d'habitude il a une
explication à donner
ce qui est bien avec Michel Pinto c'est
qu'à toute question il apporte une
réponse c'est si jamais quelqu'un qui
dit je ne sais pas pour Michel Pinto il
y a pas de question gênantes il a un
aplomb et une répartie qui lui permet de
produire des réponses
de façon très spontanée le fromager
propose donc une troisième version des
faits toujours le dîner avec sa femme et
les trois futurs victimes le départ du
trio ensuite Pinto les rejoints il
surprend le commando et se cache
il est dans un bosquet et devant la
maison il voit le trio à Genouillé avec
des hommes revêtus de cagoule le plus
récalcitrant c'était Calligaris
et il sera tué avec cette vanneur rifle
une fois le triple assassinat commis et
les trois corps emportés par les
agresseurs Pinto explique qu'il récupère
sa 22 long rifle qui forcément leur est
désigné souvenez-vous c'est justement
cette arme qu'il avait offert à
Benmokhtar
ça va être de l'orifle était posé
sur le mur contre le mur de la villa et
par conséquent le plus naturellement du
monde mais récupère cet arme et puis le
plus naturellement du monde va la cacher
voilà la dernière version que servira
Michel pinotto concernant l'effet du 27
février 99 au soir seulement cette
dernière version va-t-elle permettre à
Pinto de convaincre les jurés après cinq
jours d'audience le jury se retire pour
prendre sa décision après trois heures
de délibérer Michel pineteau a été
condamné à 30 ans de prison assorti
d'une peine de sûreté de 20 ans
je suis sidéré que dans un dossier aussi
vide que celui là
avec un avocat général qui se plaît à
dire on aimerait savoir
on n'est plus condamné
immédiatement Michel Pinto décide de
faire appel un choix pour le moins
risqué
[Musique]
on se dit
il est fou quoi parce que il va aller se
prendre perpète en appel à Aix et là un
coup de théâtre exceptionnel
4 ans après son premier procès Michel
Pinto est de nouveau dans les box des
accusés cela fait maintenant 7 ans qu'il
est en prison il a 68 ans et le fromager
de Juan-les-Pins a perdu de sa superbe
il est beaucoup moins combatif et moins
bavard ce qui n'est peut-être pas un
désavantage ça l'a beaucoup servi dans
l'image parce que les jurés autant qu'on
peut s'imaginer en plus se dire mais
c'est pas possible c'est pas lui il a
pas pu avoir fait ça tout seul pour ce
second procès la défense s'appuie sur
une nouvelle stratégie Michel Pinto
aurait-il dit la vérité dès son premier
interrogatoire il n'est qu'un simple
témoin d'humeurtre et il aurait aidé le
commando à se débarrasser des corps sous
la contrainte mais dans ce cas pourquoi
lui-même n'a-t-il pas été assassiné les
avocats de Pinto ont une explication
[Musique]
puisqu'ils l'ont laissé partir c'est que
c'était tellement signé pinoto ce crime
que eux les vrais auteurs ne risquent
rien ça a été un des arguments
développés si ma mémoire ne le trahit
pas par Maître Dupont-Moretti un
argument crédible car Michel Pinto
connaissait les victimes il a passé la
soirée avec elle et en plus c'est son
arme qui a servi à tuer Jean-Pierre
Caligaris mais ce n'est pas tout la
défense va tenter de détourner
l'attention de la cour sur un autre
suspect possible ce qui se passe avec
c'est que le principal avocat l'avocat
de la défense qui Éric Dupond-Moretti
à l'audience trouve une faille dans le
témoignage du célèbre Monsieur Jacques
l'homme qui aurait révélé aux enquêteurs
le fameux dîner organisé par Michel
pinotto avec les trois victimes le soir
du meurtre c'est lui aussi souvenez-vous
qui avait déménagé la villa de Francis
Ben Mokhtar l'homme possédait un agenda
que son patron lui avait offert et selon
maître Dupont-Moretti l'avocat du
fromager Monsieur Jacques cesse de le
remplir le 27 février 1999 précisément
le jour de la mort des trois victimes il
était tellement bouleversé par la
disparition de son ami que à partir de
cette date il n'a plus
la plus écrit dans cette année il l'a
gardé comme comme un souvenir cet agenda
va s'arrêter le jour de la disparition
et non pas le jour de la découverte des
corps
et l'avocat lui pose la question mais
comment saviez-vous que il a disparu le
27 février puisque
les corps ont été identifiés que plus de
20 mois après et donc le doute est entré
dans la tête des jurés à cet instant le
procès bascule et si Michel Pino n'était
pas l'auteur du triple meurtre reste que
pinoto à menti mais pour la défense ça
n'est plus un argument suffisant pour
condamner et voici pourquoi
il a menti parce que il a l'argent de
Batman Mokhtar et qu'il a pas voulu
qu'il a pas voulu le rendre il la menti
parce qu'il a caché la mort de même
Mokhtar parce que il a voulu garder il
garder cet argent mais est-ce que à
mensonge on fait ce commentaire fait
forcément un assassin
malgré les doutes l'avocat général
requiert à nouveau 30 ans de prison à
l'encontre de Michel Pinto reste à
savoir maintenant ce que décideront les
12 jurés
on ne peut pas imaginer que pinoto était
le seul auteur des faits donc on les
envoie délibérés finalement avec cette
incertitude
après plusieurs heures de délibération
le verdict tombe et c'est un incroyable
revirement de la justice qui s'opère
alors qu'il avait été condamné à 30 ans
de prison en première instance le
fromager est 7 fois a quitté et donc
définitivement innocenté pour le triple
meurtre de l'espérance
donc il est innocent vérité judiciaire
pour vol mais pas pour le pour
l'assassinat des trois personnes
quand d'emprisonnement pour le vol et le
recel de l'argent de Benmokhtar une
peine déjà couverte par la détention
préventive effectuée par Michel Pinto le
fromager est donc libre Monsieur Jacques
quant à lui n'a jamais été poursuivi par
la justice
le triple crime de restaurant n'a jamais
été officiellement résolu par la justice
mais alors qui a tué le 27 février 1999
Francis Benmokhtar s'accompagne Teresa
et Jean-Pierre Caligaris
où est le butin de Benmokhtar d'un
million de dollars près de 750 000 euros
contenu dans la fameuse glacière
22 ans après la vallée de l'eston
[Musique]